[Music]
market researchers conducted a study
comparing the salaries of managers at a
large nationwide retail store the
researchers obtained salary and
demographic data for a random sample of
managers
the researchers calculated the average
salary of the men in the sample and the
average salary of the women in the
sample
they want to test if managers who are
men have a higher average salary than
managers who are women
assume that all conditions for inference
have been met
which of these is the most appropriate
test and alternative hypothesis and we
can see they're talking about a paired
t-test and a two-sample t-test and then
they talk about the alternative
hypotheses
so pause this video and try to figure
this out on your own
so first let's think about the
difference between a paired t-test and a
two-sample t-test in a paired t-test
we're going to construct hypotheses
around
a parameter for a population that will
often be the mean difference so we have
one population so we're talking about
the paired situation right over here and
so let's say we say hey do
do people
run faster when they wear shorts or
pants and so for each member of the
population you could see what you would
if you really had perfect information
you know how fast do they run with pants
and how fast do they run with shorts and
then you would calculate the difference
and then across the whole population you
could actually get that mean difference
so the mean difference of pants
minus shorts
and of course in order to estimate that
or in order to do a hypothesis test
around that you would take a sample and
then you would calculate the
sample
mean of the difference of pants
minus shorts
and then you would say hey
assuming the null hypothesis is true you
would construct some null hypothesis
likely that there is no that this mean
is zero and you would say hey if the
null hypothesis is true that this is
actually equal to zero what's the
probability that i got this result if
that's below your significance level
then you would reject your null
hypothesis and it would suggest the
alternative that might be that hey maybe
this mean is greater than zero on the
other hand a two-sample t-test is where
you're thinking about two different
populations for example you could be
thinking about a population of men and
you could be thinking about the
population of women and you want to
compare the means between these two say
the mean salary so you have the mean
salary for
men
and you have the mean
salary for women
and what you're trying to do with the
hypothesis test is try to come up with
some conclusions about the mean
difference between these two parameters
so the mean salary for men
minus the mean salary for women
and our null hypothesis is usually the
no news here hypothesis and so in this
situation our null hypothesis is that
there is no difference between these
means and that our alternative
hypothesis in the situation that we are
looking at because they want to test if
managers who are men have a higher
average salary if they just wanted to
test that whether managers who are men
have a different salary then our
alternative hypothesis would look
something like this where the mean
of men minus the mean of women
is not equal to zero but they aren't
just testing to see if the means are
different they want to see if men have a
higher average salary so instead of not
equal 0 there we would have
greater than zero for our alternative
hypothesis
so which choice is that well we're
clearly in a two-sample t-test situation
and we want to do the greater than not
the not equal to so we are in that
choice right over there